The Luria-Delbrück experiment excited many biologists,
but there was skepticism because of the unfamiliarity
with the methodology. And Joshua Lederberg was
a budding young bacteriologist who developed a new method
that could allow him to validate the conclusions of Luria-Delbrück with a method that was much more
familiar to the rest of the biologists, and therefore could be accepted by them,
as you know,
an approach they could understand. And what he basically figured out was
that you could actually make prints of bacteria.
And the simple concept is you spread bacteria onto a Petri dish,
and then they will grow up generating progeny on those plates.
You could transfer some of those progeny to a velvet, and then
place another bacterium on top of the velvet and transfer the bacterium from the velvet onto the new
Petri plates.
So it's very much like a printing press, where you have a master block and you put ink on it,
and then you take that block and some of the ink gets transferred to the first page, and some of the ink gets transferred to the
second page, and the third page. And that technique is called replica plating.
So you could take bacterium that were spread on the plate,
lots of them,
and you could now transfer some of their progeny to a plate,
which had,
for example,
T1 spread on it. In the spontaneous mutation model, the prediction would be
that if there was a bacterium on the master that was T1 resistant,
some of its progeny would be transferred to the plate in exactly the same place on each of the plates.
So again,
by the printing press analogy,
if you have over here on the printing press you have and E,
and it's got some ink on it,
and you put four different pieces of paper onto the master,
the E will appear at the exact same place on each of the replicas because the E was
preexisting in the master.
And so that is the very simple concept.
If the spontaneous mutation had occurred prior to any exposure to T1,
there should be progeny all together on a particular part of the plate,
and I will transfer them to three different plates,
the new colony should appear,
the new resistant cell should appear in exactly the same place on all the plates.
Lederberg predicted a very different outcome if the mutations were being induced.
In that experiment, transferring cells from the master to the plate
with T1, some random cells somewhere on the plate will change to T1
resistance on that plate and give rise to a colony.
Those same cells,
when transferred to another plate, a resistant cell will appear randomly someplace else on the
plate.
So resistant colonies should not be at the same place on the different
plates because it was not predetermined by whether there was a resistant cell the
existing master.